[Music]
dave is in virginia beach hi dave
welcome to the ramsay show
hi guys thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
i am a 15 uh 51 year old single no kids
i'm feeling stuck in a rut and wondering
how to get better traction
uh the job looks stable for i'd say the
next three years
looks real solid with the contract
income is about 69 000. you got about 12
000 in checking a rut on what what kind
of rut yeah what do you write a career
a psychological run a relationship right
it's pretty much a financial rut oh okay
and let's see 401k i've only got about
62
000. i owed 10
500 on a car and 45
000 on the house where do you want to be
where do you want to be with your money
i just
really i'm almost having anxiety about
getting out of debt
yeah why as quickly as possible
you mean you're having anxiety that's
telling you to get out of debt or
to not to get out get out of debt okay
to get out of debt okay so the debt is
bothering you that's good anxiety okay
yeah yeah i guess it is a good it's an
alarm telling you your house is on fire
and it is
right yeah you're right so you have a
ten thousand dollar car debt what other
debt
house 45 whatever um house
uh that's it but i do have some upcoming
uh remodeling expenses like a new roof
and a few other things i'm thinking
that's going to be about sixteen
thousand
are you running off on it till uh 69
000 without overtime i make more when
there's overtime available what do you
do
i do design work computer design okay
cool good for you
so you got side hustle available to you
if you wanted to as well
all right and so let me get this
straight 55
000 plus 16 for the rehab
uh would be like 75 000
we'll call it all right changes your
whole life
it lets you breathe and let you sleep
right
your house is paid off your car's paid
off and your house is rehabbed you don't
have a payment in the stinking world and
you make 70 grand a year it changes your
life doesn't it
yeah so we need 75 000 you're a single
guy making 51
oh there's 51 that's making 70. if i
need 75
that's 35 a year for two years
that's overtime on top of overtime
hitting the gas having some fun
not much how's this working knowing i'm
working towards the goal
oh yeah totally yeah that's the end goal
is fun but right now for two years you
don't have a life
you do beans and rice rice and beans and
all you do is work
and you become completely debt-free with
your house rehabbed
and you're 53. i'm already feeling
better
in that contract you're worried about
going away in four years
that that contract you're worried about
going away in 4 years
it doesn't you're debt-free right
yeah yeah that's a good point if you
don't have any payments in the world
could you
actually start doing some investing and
become wealthy answer is yes
yeah absolutely i know that and when
you're not so anxious and knotted up and
tied up could you go hang out with some
other people get connected to a
community have some fun yes
yeah yeah probably so not probably 100
percent
well we call it financial peace two
words that don't go together like fouchy
math
right okay so
all right so 35 000 a year for two years
yeah you can do it and i'll help you i'm
gonna send you a copy of the book the
total money makeover it's gonna show you
exactly how to do this
step by step okay oh awesome dave i
appreciate that big time
you hang on kelly i'll pick up we'll get
you going call us back when you're
debt-free and tell us about your journey
i want to hear your success story you
can do this man yes
i think you just need a little bit of a
clear path and
you're the man you're gonna get her done
baby